we're outside just to show you the
operative the reactivity of this lovely
Sofia liquid oxygen so you can see
wonderful liquid oxygen nice blue color
so on the over here on the table we've
got a tin tray which we're going to use
to to contain the experiment that I'm
going to show you next so we've got our
favorite liquid oxygen there strongly
oxidizing very very reactive and here
I've got some cotton wool so this is the
same stuff that we used to like take
makeup off
perhaps our partners or our girlfriends
or our wives and it's the same stuff
that we used to wipe our baby's bums
oxygen is an interesting element because
it exists in two forms the tall form
which we breathe all the time is o two
two oxygen atoms joined together and
there's another form called ozone in
which has three atoms arranged like a
letter V or letter V this way up oxygen
has unpaired electrons within the
molecular orbitals in the atomic
orbitals around the structure and these
unpaired electrons give rise to color
and that color is blue so blue is often
perceived to be the color of solvated or
unpaired electrons and you can see here
the lovely blue color now lots of
chemists are really scared when they see
the blue of liquid oxygen because liquid
oxygen is very very reactive generally
you only make liquid oxygen by mistake
not like today when we're making some on
purpose and if you've made it in by
mistake in an uncontrolled way where
there might be organic molecules perhaps
simple organic chemicals like
hydrocarbons grease or perhaps a highly
elaborate compound and they tend to
detonate and they tend to cause very
energetic experiments so yeah it's
really fluffy it's not very reactive
doesn't really burn cinders make might
smolder but here we go we're going to
pop it in the tray and then we're going
to fill up all of the void space so all
of the space between the cut the carb
the cotton particles with oxygen so you
might want to stand back after this bit
Brady so here we go is our liquid oxygen
trying to come in and zoom in on Timmy
okay so here you can see the lovely blue
liquid oxygen color going into the to
the cotton wall particles - here we have
a match on a stick
and I think you can see it's probably a
light so we have our fire we have our
oxygen and we have our fuel now let's
see what happens if we put them all
together you ready okay oh and there she
blows and ozone is much more reactive
than oxygen so near the Earth's surface
where we you and I are at the moment
ozone is really quite dangerous because
if you breathe it in it can start
reacting with the any sort of molecule
that has bonds between carbon but in the
upper atmosphere ozone is extremely
important because it absorbs ultraviolet
light that comes from the Sun and stops
this ultraviolet light attacking the
molecules in biological species on the
surface if it wasn't for the ozone in
the upper atmosphere all of us would be
if not dead certainly very much less
comfortable than we are at the moment so
Neil is now connecting up a piece of
that a piece of tube to the oxygen
cylinder and he's going to fill up this
gas jar with oxygen and we're going to
do a really classic experiment the one
that everyone learns at school a test
for oxygen which is to relight a glowing
splint so we have a traditional gas jar
full of oxygen so here you can see we're
burning a splint okay so this is the
wood burning in excess oxygen around us
okay so now what we're going to do is
we're going to take the splint out so
that is just glowing so if I blow on the
splint you can see it gets brighter now
we're going to try and relight that
splint by putting it into a very
oxygen-rich atmosphere so we'll move
over to the jar and we'll put in our
glowing splint and you can see the flame
comes back to life so that's a test that
everyone learns for an oxygen-rich
environment
well the increased oxygen content called
concentration reignites and reinitiate
that oxidation of the of the water
the burning of the wood so we'll do that
again so there we go flame again